[Music]
[Music]
at its worst
we scientists we debase ourselves as
mere tools of
tribal warfare
anything that we do is our choice and
our action right how we utilize a tool
whether it's to save something in our
lives or to lead to our downfall is
entirely up to the human beings who
wield it
we are inseparable from these
technologies
but somewhere in the 20th century we
crossed a threshold
where our worst errors are now in range
of being
existential events
brings a lot of fear and it brings a lot
of
hope and this is exactly you know
the issue is that it's not showing the
truth
hello my name's marianne c cart we're
here to debate whether we should see
science as our savior
or our downfall from climate change to
nuclear weapons
surveillance to resource depletion
science is increasingly in the firing
line
many people as a result are highly
critical of science and the
organizations it seemed to sustain
from agribusiness and military spending
to big pharma
and big tech yet faced with a global
pandemic
the same critics look to science for the
solutions to find vaccines
to create drugs to fight the disease to
efficiently manufacture and distribute
billions of items of protective
equipment
so should we end this hypocrisy and see
science as our savior
or has technological advance led
humanity into a
dark and troubling world from which we
need to reverse
so is the politics of science and
technology central to the future
well we've got a fantastic panel to
debate this today
uh ganesh taylor is a genetic researcher
and science communicator
she's currently working at the francis
crick institute where
her research focuses mainly on the
genetic formation of ovaries and testes
mark edwards is a professor of civil and
environmental engineering at virginia
tech
he was one of the most prominent
whistleblowers in the flint water crisis
and his scientific work caused the city
of flint the state of michigan
and the united states to declare a state
of emergency
luke julia is the co-creator of apple's
voice assistant siri
he's an expert in human machine
interactions and he's co-founded
a number of startups in silicon valley
and finally brett weinstein is an
american biologist and evolutionary
theorist
he's one of the founding members of the
intellectual dark web
which now lists sam harris jordan
peterson and joe rogan as avid members
brett also co-hosts the dark horse
podcast
with his wife heather each of our
panelists is going to have two minutes
to pitch
their take on the question is science
our savior or our downfall and after
that
we'll go to a debate so first of all
ganesh
so first disclaimer of course is the
fact that i'm an academic scientist
which kind of makes my opinion somewhat
partisan one might say so in these two
minutes i want to share my personal
opinion
um as somebody who's been studying for a
while and considers themselves to
operate under this label of
scientists so is science our savior or
our downfall
i mean my answer to that question
therefore has to be
well science is a tool a way of thinking
a methodology with which we interrogate
the world that we live in
and therefore it is neither our savior
nor our downfall
we assume that it will be our savior
because we value truth and reality and
understanding the world that we're in
and based on that we see it as our
savior but anything that we do
is our choice and our action right how
we utilize a tool
whether it's to save something in our
lives or to lead to our downfall is
entirely up to the human beings who
wield it
now that said as i said i'm a i'm an
academic scientist
so and something that i always think is
worth saying in these contexts
is that you know scientists are human
beings too
namely they have their opinions they
have their politics they live in their
bubbles and as such
there might be something of concern in
in the question
is academia a monoculture
i think so um what
is good or what is bad is defined by
human beings and if you find yourself in
a culture that
predominantly believes one thing or
another thing to be good one creates a
sort of echo chamber of sorts to live in
and i think that that might be something
that could be really quite dangerous in
the context of
science one might say and um
just finally i guess another sort of
abstraction from that point
would be the question of funding so um
right now i'm
standing in the francis quick institute
which is you know a new biomedical
institution built in london
it's a very collaborative place many
people have put money into it
but money is what keeps it afloat and we
have to be realistic about that
and it's those funders who determine to
a large extent
what type of research is deemed
appropriate or fundable or of interest
to the public
and so you know to loop back to the
question is science going
to be our savior or our downfall in a
very sort of academic sense
and that path to one thing or another
which of course it's never going to be
so absolute it'll probably be a mixture
of both
but that path is being laid right now by
the decisions of funding organizations
on what they choose to
allow scientists to pursue then
percolate it through
the monocultures i would posit of
academia
and then ultimately result in whatever
outputs we have and then
and as i said i'm completely partisan i
see science as academic science but of
course
after what the academic research
institutions have done it gets passed on
to the tech companies and
how that gets turned into tools is sort
of outside of that scope
mark edwards now science it
always has the capability to be our
savior
our downfall or both at the same time
and at its best scientists we
create technological breakthroughs and
dramatically improve the odds of solving
problems and
productively deploying resources at its
worst
we scientists we debase ourselves as
mere tools of
tribal warfare this has happened
eugenics in the hands of perverted
scientists led to the rise of the nazi
party and the final solution
that was our downfall in the same era
the shankoism in the hands of russian
citizen scientists created
great famines and great terror
that was our downfall but we've always
bounced back
and yet there's always the ever present
chance that this time is different
and we won't i think
my main fear is that modern day
scientists too
frequently lack in moral humility
moral courage and trustworthiness given
the climate
that we live in i'd feel a lot better
if scientists were more aware of our
history
both the good and the bad and
if a majority of scientists were as
dangerously naive as i was at age 40
before i got a rude awakening
we are really in great danger
certainly the fate of humankind depends
on the path we take
and i think that is the promise the
glory
and the curse of modern science thank
you
and luke julia oh good afternoon
um so i'm not going to talk about
science in general because
you know it's it's way too fast for me
but i'm going to talk about the one that
i know
and the one that i know is artificial
intelligence right so
everybody is talking about artificial
intelligence for the past
few years i mean a lot of people are
talking about it and
this is one of the issues you know of
artificial intelligence is that
people are talking about it like if it
were you know
something done by hollywood basically uh
and so uh so it brings a lot of fear
and it brings a lot of hope and this is
exactly you know the the issue is that
it's not showing the truth
so the main issue that i have in
engineering with science and with mine
in particular
is that people are not educated about it
and so most of the most of the issues
is that you know uh we are hearing a lot
of things but we are not trying to
understand what it means so i wouldn't
say that
you know exactly like the people before
me
um that it's one or the other i mean
it's actually both of them and it
depends on us
i mean uh artificial intelligence and
usually i call that you know artificial
intelligences
uh they are basically only tools and
those tools they are in our hands
and we have you know the full power
of doing whatever we want with those
tools and uh
and once the society is educated about
those tools
the society has to decide how to use it
so we need to
regulate basically and the regulation is
going to help us
you know to decide how to use that the
regulation can happen at a lot a lot of
different levels right so it can happen
at
my personal level me as a scientist you
know so
i have my own ethics and i decided not
to use or not the thing what
that discover and then you know i'm
going to see that on the in the group
that i'm
belong to can be the company it can be
the country it can be the world so to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas